(bright music)
- So I owe everyone an apology.
The episode of "Real Lawyer Reacts"
that I just released
involved some reactions
that are not my first
reactions to the show.
In fairness,
I had to think about it for months
to untangle all of the legal issues,
but I need to do better.
I need to be able to react
to these things in real time.
You've come to expect it.
And for that,
I'm sorry that it took me so long.
All I can ask is for your forgiveness.
So please,
don't watch this episode
of "Real Lawyer Reacts" to
"Better Call Saul" chicanery.
Don't watch the hilarious observations
and me basically falling apart trying
to untangle all of the legal issues.
You deserve better.
- This chicanery,
he's done worse.
- You deserve better.
So please exercise some restraint
and do not click on the link
to watch this episode
of "Real Lawyer Reacts,"
to "Better Call Saul."
(bright music)